Nous avons repris les dimanches derniers notre série d'études sur la lettre d'Epaul au Galate,
cette église qui avait un très beau début en étant implantée par l'apôtre Paul lui-même,
mais qui a souffert à une influence tellement mauvaise qu'il risquait, malgré leur bon début,
ils risquaient d'être considérés comme exclus de la grâce par exemple.
Donc leur péché était très proche du péché d'Anathème, de nier l'évangile lui-même.
Quand on pense à ça, on pense que les plus grands risques de cette église c'était de tomber dans l'immoralité sexuelle,
mais à la base c'était d'avoir un rapport légaliste avec Dieu.
De considérer, malgré leur expérience de conversion qui était palpable,
tous dans cette église étaient conscients, tous les croyants authentiques à cette église,
qui semblent être vraiment la majorité sinon la totalité des Galates.
La réalité c'est que ces personnes-là ont eu une expérience si puissante
que Paul lui-même était tellement convaincu de leur conversion authentique,
car il dit dans Galates,
« avait vu reçu les Saint-Esprits par les œuvres de la loi »
ou
par la prédication de la foi.
Donc ce que Paul vise à laisser clair dans ses passages,
c'est qu'il était convaincu de la conversion authentique de cette église,
mais la déroute de cette église n'était pas l'immoralité sexuelle par exemple.
La déroute de cette église était le légalisme,
un rapport envers Dieu
qui ne prend pas en considération
que Dieu est pour nous,
que Dieu a tout fait pour nous réconcilier avec lui
et qu'il nous a insérés par la conversion
dans une relation irrévocable, insupprimable d'amour,
une atmosphère d'amour
où certes, les vrais croyants,
la vie ne sera pas caractérisée par
les péchés qui prédominaient sur sa vie en avant,
mais que de l'autre côté,
sa vie est caractérisée par une sanctification volontaire,
la manifestation de la vie des dieux.
Donc les thèmes de la lettre aux Galates principales,
c'est la rédemption dans son ensemble,
dans sa totalité.
Et ces thèmes indivisibles, inséparables,
sont abordés par ces deux aspects principaux
ou fondamentaux.
C'est que nous, pour un langage plus simple
dans les mondes évangéliques,
on va séparer entre les moments de la conversion
ou les saluts
et la sanctification,
la continuité de la vie chrétienne.
La plupart de la lettre va traiter surtout
de manière plus technique
la compréhension de comment
les saluts a lieu,
comment nous pouvons être déclarés
justes devant Dieu
et recevoir un pardon parfait.
C'est qu'Ipole
va décrire avec l'utilisation de l'expression
ou justification par la foi.
Et la manière la plus
précise d'utiliser ces termes
se dirige vers un scénario,
un langage judiciaire.
Nous sommes tous devant un tribunal
où Dieu est les juges,
les dieux trois fois cent.
Et c'est impossible
à n'importe quel être humain
d'attendre les justes exigences
de la sainteté des dieux
pour pouvoir être pardonné,
avoir accès à sa présence.
Et donc, Paul va insister
que comme c'est impossible
par les efforts humains
à cause de notre nature corrompue,
peu importe quels soient
les scénarios religieux,
même les juifs
les plus aînés
dans les contextes
les plus lourds
et ritualistes
n'ont la moindre capacité
d'obéir au moindre commandement
de manière parfaite.
Et donc, Paul va laisser
de manière très claire
que nous ne pouvons qu'être justifiés
ou, attention,
être déclarés justes
devant les tribunaux de Dieu
qui est par les mérites
d'un autre.
Cet autre, notamment,
est Christ.
C'est lui qui a pris
la forme humaine,
étant Dieu lui-même,
qui a fait la médiation parfaite
entre Dieu et homme.
Et Christ était,
avant tout,
dans son œuvre,
en train de traiter
un problème judiciaire
entre l'humanité et Dieu.
Et donc, il a dû naître
sous la loi,
il a dû naître en tant qu'homme
pour pouvoir nous représenter,
il a vécu une vie parfaite
qu'aucun d'être humain
n'arrive à vivre,
et il est mort à la croix
pour payer
pour notre transgression.
Donc, pourquoi Dieu peut
déclarer juste
les croyants,
c'est car
l'acte
de croire
ou la confiance
déposée en Christ,
illustrée par Paul,
c'est comme si on voulait
rentrer en Christ
et nous présenter
devant le tribunal
des dieux
non basé
sur notre performance
religieuse,
mais basé
sur le fait
que par la foi
on s'est tellement
associé à Christ,
c'est comme si on était
couvert de Jésus.
Et lorsqu'on s'est présent
dans ce tribunal,
au lieu de nous voir,
Dieu voit
la parfaite
obéissance
de Christ.
Et pourquoi
Dieu peut
les faire,
c'est car
au moment
où Christ
était à la croix,
Dieu n'a pas
traité Christ
tout simplement
comme son enfant.
Il a dû
traiter Christ
comme les pires
des transgresseurs.
Pourquoi ?
Car Christ
s'est présenté
comme notre représentant
devant les tribunaux
des dieux
et il a porté
sur lui
la coupabilité
de tous nos péchés.
Et donc,
Dieu n'a pas pu
épargner les Christ,
il a dû traiter Christ
comme s'il était
les pires des pécheurs
à la croix.
Lorsque nous nous présentons
devant les tribunaux
des dieux,
il ne peut exister
la moindre suggestion
que Christ
n'a pas souffert
suffisamment.
C'est-à-dire,
dans la conscience
du croyant,
la certitude principale
qu'il doit avoir,
c'est qu'il a placé
sa confiance
en Christ.
La question n'est pas
combien forte
était ma foi,
la question n'était pas
comment je rajoute
à ma foi
mes efforts religieux,
ma performance religieuse,
la question était
est-ce que la foi
était placée
au bon endroit ?
Si la foi était placée
au bon endroit,
c'est-à-dire Christ,
c'est impossible
de recevoir de la part
de Dieu
autre traitement
qu'est l'absolution
parfaite
et l'adoption
parfaite.
si on pourrait considérer
une barre d'énergie
comme les jeux vidéo,
c'est que Dieu
atteint en termes
des perfections
des vies
nous a déjà été crédité
parfaitement,
complètement plein,
rempli en Christ.
Et c'est qu'on devrait
recevoir en termes
des punitions
qui pour nous
devrait durer
pour toute l'éternité
a été condensé
et déversé sur Christ.
La double dette
est complètement payée
d'une fois pour toutes.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ça, c'est la partie
salut,
début de la foi,
justification.
Sauf que ce n'est pas
qu'une question
des déclarations légales.
Cette déclaration légale
avait pour but
de nous réconcilier
avec Dieu.
Et notre association
à Christ a été
opérée
et engendrée
par les Saint-Esprit.
Ce qui fait que
la personne qui a vraiment
placé sa foi
en Christ,
elle non seulement
a été déclarée
juste devant
les tribunaux
des dieux,
elle a été rendue
radicalement juste
par la nouvelle naissance.
Donc,
le début de la foi
n'est pas
qu'une question
légale.
C'est aussi
une question
d'union vitale,
spirituelle
avec Jésus.
et voilà pourquoi
Paul va traiter
la question
de la justification,
c'est-à-dire
comment pouvons-nous
être considérés
comme justes
devant les tribunaux
des dieux ?
La base fondamentale
objective,
c'est l'œuvre
du Christ
et sa personne.
La base
expérimentale
subjective,
c'est cette
transformation des vies
qui a été opérée
en nous
lorsqu'on est
unis à Christ.
Et donc,
Paul va étendre
la conception
de la justification
par la foi,
non seulement
comme une déclaration
légale de la part
des dieux,
mais une transformation
progressive
qui a eu
un déclenchement,
un départ,
mais qui ne peut
être plus
supprimable,
qui ne peut
n'y pas réussir.
Même si la vie
du croyant
peut être
oscillante,
parfois ponctuellement
souffrir
des rechutes
ou des péritages,
en fructifères,
s'il a été
véritablement
lié à Dieu
par la foi
en Jésus-Christ,
cette sémence
que Dieu a placée
en nous,
c'est-à-dire
les Saint-Esprits,
est une sémence
qui ne s'éphone pas,
est un don
irrévocable.
Et cette personne,
plus tôt ou plus tard,
sera redressée
sous l'enfance
du Saint-Esprit.
Ce qui fait
que ce type
d'enseignement
soit très avertissant
pour une auto-évaluation
personnelle
et que l'Église
soit diligente
et responsable
pour avoir
une observation
suffisante
lorsqu'elle va
vouloir reconnaître
certaines personnes
comme vraies,
croyantes ou non,
sachant qu'elle ne sera
jamais parfaite
dans ses jugements,
mais qu'elle doit agir
de manière responsable
quand elle va baptiser
quelqu'un
ou pratiquer la discipline.
et c'est surtout
un avertissement
pour une auto-évaluation
personnelle,
auto-évaluation
afin que
la plus grande question
qu'on essaie
de traiter
chez nous
soit,
mais soit pas
comment
maintenir mon salut
ou comment
ne pas perdre
mon salut.
Cette question
n'est pas
du tout biblique.
La question biblique,
c'est est-ce que
je suis véritablement
sauvé ?
Moi,
je dois évaluer
cette question
dans ma vie personnelle
et nous allons avoir
une idée
parfaitement certaine
à propos d'un autre,
mais nous pouvons avoir
une idée
suffisamment assurée
par rapport à nous-mêmes.
Et on ne peut pas
juger une personne
par les moments
les plus faibles
de sa vie,
mais nous allons
considérer
les évidences
surtout
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit
dans sa vie.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul
cherche à corriger
cette notion
en expliquant
ce qui est
la conception
de l'Évangile
qui sauve,
qui est inséparable
et cohérent
avec l'Évangile
qui sanctifie.
Et ici,
donc,
à partir
du chapitre,
la moitié
et la fin
du chapitre 4
et surtout
à partir
du chapitre 5,
il fait la transition
entre les traitements
et cette déclaration
légale,
les points de départ
qui nous justifient,
et de ce qu'on appelle
la sanctification
ou la manière
dont Dieu nous rend
juste.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Le Saint-Esprit,
le Saint-Esprit,
il a un lieu
central
dans la considération
de cette sanctification.
Déjà,
il ne pourrait pas
être donné
si Christ n'avait pas
accompli parfaitement.
C'est les dons
les plus importants
des promesses divines
de l'Ancien Testament,
de la Nouvelle Alliance.
Si la condition
pour que nous recevions
le Saint-Esprit
soit l'accomplissement
parfait de l'œuvre
du Christ,
c'est impossible
qu'on soit capable
aujourd'hui
de commettre
quelque chose
pour laquelle
Christ n'a pas
payé suffisamment
et pour plus
que les chrétiens
véritables puissent
attrister les Saint-Esprits,
s'il est un vrai chrétien,
il ne veut pas
supprimer les Saint-Esprits.
Les Saint-Esprits,
il est tout-puissant.
Nous, non.
Lorsqu'on était
dans notre pire condition,
Dieu a décidé
de nous sauver.
Et après la conversion,
aucun chrétien
pour plus qu'il pratique
quelque part
des péchés assez graves
dans les mois ponctuels,
il n'est pas pire
que ce qu'il était
un jour
avant sa conversion.
Et donc ici,
ce que l'apôtre Paul
cherche,
c'est de décrire
et de nous faire comprendre
la sanctification.
On a déjà vu
l'importance
de comprendre
la vision biblique
à propos de la sanctification.
C'est là où je pense
que les manques
des progrès
dans la sanctification
dans l'Église
d'une manière générale
dans nos jours,
est liée directement
au manque
de compréhension
de comment
la sanctification
fonctionne
selon la Bible.
Et c'est intéressant
de remarquer ici
pour ne pas perdre
l'atmosphère,
je dirais,
du texte,
les langages
utilisés
pour décrire
la sanctification,
les saluts
ou la sanctification.
Donc ici,
nous sommes devant
un langage
qui présente
la sanctification
comme une question
légale,
donc justifiée,
rendue juste
et comme j'ai dit,
ça a à voir
directement
avec les rôles
du Christ
dans notre salut.
Si Christ a vécu
une vie parfaite,
il a mort à la croix
pour payer pour nos péchés,
tout est payé
et donc cette déclaration
légale dépend
de la vie
et de l'œuvre du Christ,
ce n'est pas
de ma performance
et cette transformation
qui me sanctifie,
elle est aussi
car j'étais légitimement
par la foi liée à Christ,
donc sa vie
vit en moi,
donc la vie du Christ
va se manifester
dans ma vie.
donc la thématique
du tribunal.
Ensuite,
il y a aussi
le langage
de la liberté,
donc loin d'être
considéré
la sanctification
du chrétien
comme toujours
très négative,
toujours en interdition,
toujours en résistant
à des passions
charnelles,
au plaisir de la vie,
camisole de force,
au contraire,
ici nous sommes
devant la vraie liberté.
La vraie liberté,
c'est
d'être,
pourquoi on a été
créé pour être.
C'est de satisfaire
nos demandes
les plus profondes,
c'est de satisfaire
les buts
de notre existence.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que
les membres
des libertés,
c'était l'esclavage
du péché
et l'esclavage
de la culpabilité,
même ayant
la lumière de la loi.
Car la loi
me rappelait
ce que ma conscience
me rappelle,
même si on peut
cauteriser,
mais la loi,
en me rappelant
ces choses,
ne me donnait
jamais la capacité
de les accomplir
comme il faut.
parfois,
elle provoquait
plutôt la tentation
qu'elle nous fournissait,
c'est ce dont on a besoin
pour nous sanctifier.
Et donc,
Paul,
les juifs,
les pharisiens,
pour plus aînés
qu'ils étaient
avant leur conversion,
à cause
de l'infirmité
de la chair,
la loi
provoquait
plutôt la tentation
et une obéissance
qui n'était
qu'externe
et très incohérente
envers d'autres
réserves de leur vie
où ils pouvaient
s'habiller
de manière très cachée
à l'extérieur
mais complètement
pourri à l'intérieur.
Qu'ils pouvaient
donner des sacrifices
et des dons
très importants
à l'église
ou plutôt
au temple,
mais qu'en même temps,
ils disaient aux personnes
que ça,
c'est sacré,
mais les personnes
pouvaient négliger
les supports
qu'ils devraient donner
à leurs parents,
par exemple.
Et donc ici,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que les langages
de la liberté
nous montrent
que même
cette obéissance
extérieure superficielle
de la loi
était un esclavage
qui nous faisait
qu'accroître
la culpabilité
des hypocrites
religieux.
Par contre,
au salut,
on a été
affranchis
de l'esclavage
de la loi
qui nous condamnait
tous les temps
et bien sûr
de l'esclavage
du péché
qui nous empêchait
d'utiliser la loi
de manière
à produire
les vrais fruits
de l'esprit.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est qu'à partir
du moment
où Christ
nous a affranchis,
Paul va dire
en Galate,
c'est pour la liberté
qui vous avait été
affranchis.
Donc on a été
affranchis,
donc la conception
de la liberté,
c'est affranchis
d'un esclavage.
mais on n'est pas
affranchis
d'un esclavage
pour rester
esclave
de la religion.
On n'est pas
affranchis
d'esclavage
pour continuer
d'avoir
un égard
envers Dieu
comme s'il était
un tyran
très intéressé
à trouver
la moindre faute
afin de nous punir,
de nous virer,
de nous chasser
comme c'était
le cas
de l'esclave.
C'est l'esprit
d'adoption
qui prend lieu
et donc
si on a été
affranchis
de l'esclavage,
c'était pour la liberté,
la liberté
est ici décrite
comme,
attention,
ma nouvelle volonté
comme étant
la volonté
de cette nouvelle nature
qui est refaite
à l'image
de Dieu,
c'est de retrouver
une aspiration
prédominante
en moi
qui va
dans la direction
de vouloir être
en relation avec Dieu
et refléter sa vie,
de vivre la vie
que Dieu vit.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que
la liberté
envers laquelle
on a été affranchis
de l'esclavage
du péché,
c'est une liberté
où les croyants
ont pour ambition
suprême
être sains,
plaire Dieu,
être en relation
avec Dieu,
imiter Dieu.
C'est ce qui va
nous introduire
dans un autre langage
aussi dans ces passages
qui est le langage
de l'amour.
Là,
on est devant un texte
qui nous parle
d'héritage,
de filiation.
On n'a pas tout simplement
été affranchis,
pardonnés
dans ces tribunaux
pour être épargnés
de l'enfer.
On a été affranchis
afin de vivre
la liberté d'enfant
dans une atmosphère
d'amour.
Voilà pourquoi
Paul dans ces passages
nous rappelle
que toute la loi
est accomplie
dans une seule parole,
aimer Dieu
et les prochains.
Donc,
c'est cette vie
d'amour sans,
d'amour qui scientifie,
un amour enraciné
dans l'amour
qu'on a reçu
des dieux
et qui s'est reproduit
envers les autres.
Et donc,
ici,
c'est intéressant,
Paul va dire
par la charité
dévené
au rendez-vous
au service
les uns aux autres
et
toute la loi
est accomplie
par une seule parole.
Donc,
c'est l'amour
pour Dieu le Père
qui devient
la nouvelle position légale.
Les juges
qui nous ont pardonnés
est un Père
qui nous a adoptés.
Et les chrétiens,
c'est lui
qui a expérimenté
cette transformation
à son intérieur.
Au moment où
il a placé sa foi
de manière authentique
à Christ,
il n'a plus
les ressentis
d'être tout simplement
un esclave,
mais il est
un enfant.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
son aspiration,
c'est de manifester
dans sa vie pratique
son amour pour Dieu,
son allégance à Dieu
et son amour
pour les prochains.
Donc,
la substance,
l'atmosphère
de cette liberté
est l'amour.
On ne saurait pas
expliquer parfaitement
de quelle manière
ça nous motive
à nous sanctifier.
Et c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
l'emphase biblique,
c'est les vrais chrétiens,
lorsqu'ils expérimentent
la vraie répentance,
ils n'est pas
si tant préoccupés
par son péché
avec les conséquences
qu'il peut souffrir,
la terreur
ou les menaces
de perdre les saluts,
il est tout simplement
profondément attristé
d'avoir attristé
les cœurs de son père.
Son ambition
n'est pas
de vouloir mériter
les bénédictions
de Dieu.
Son ambition,
c'est de plaire
les cœurs
de son père.
Et des savoirs,
au moment où on tombe,
qu'il nous aime
malgré tout
et que son amour
nous sanctifie,
comme l'Écrit
s'a fait avec Pierre,
après qu'il ait réuni
les Christs,
ça a une puissance
infiniment plus puissante
dans la vie
de vrai croyant
pour qu'il puisse
rebondir
de plus profond
de trous de péché
et mêler une vie
encore plus sainte
et fructifère
qu'il n'avait avant.
Et qui fait parfois
qu'une personne
qui expérimente
un shoot,
parfois réviant,
plus robuste
dans sa foi
qu'une personne
qui a toujours
donné l'apparence
de ne jamais
avoir shooté.
C'est comme Augustin disait,
je te remercie
du pardon des péchés
que tu m'as pourvus,
mais je te remercie
également
de ne pas avoir permis
que je tombe plus.
tous les mérites
à la grâce de Dieu.
Donc les langages
sont langages d'amour.
Et c'est un langage,
bien sûr,
qui est le langage
prédominant dans les passages,
le langage
du Saint-Esprit.
Le Saint-Esprit
est celui
qui au moment
de la conversion
nous a régénérés
pour qu'on puisse
avoir nos égards
tournés vers l'Évangile,
comprendre l'Évangile
comme il faut,
nous répentir
et croire.
Il nous a appelés
efficacement,
il nous a régénérés,
il nous a unis à Christ.
C'est le Saint-Esprit
qui porte
cet affranchissement
du péché,
c'est le Saint-Esprit
aussi qui porte
la sanctification.
C'est car
Dieu
nous a envoyé
son Esprit
pour notre salut
que nous avons
l'assurance
que ce même Esprit
va produire en nous
la restauration
progressive
de l'image
de Dieu
en nous
car c'est l'Esprit
de Dieu
qui nous unit à Christ,
il est appelé
l'Esprit du Christ,
il est celui
qui nous unit,
il est le lien
spirituel
qui nous unit à Christ.
Tous ces rappels
sont très importants
car nous voyons
l'œuvre de la Trinité
partout dans les passages,
cet amour paternel
du Père,
ces pardons judiciaires
pourvus par les fils
et cette sanctification
ou plutôt cette liberté
qu'on expérimente
car cette influence
envers notre nouvelle volonté
nous motive
à désirer véritablement
vivre,
c'est pourquoi
on a été créé.
Le Saint-Esprit
a donc l'origine directe
mais il a aussi
l'influence continue
prédominante
sur la nouvelle nature.
Il est la troisième
personne de la Sainte Trinité
et son influence
s'exerce envers nous
depuis la source
de l'être
et se porte
vers l'extérieur
par les fruits.
Quand on pense
à la sanctification
selon l'enseignement
de l'apôtre Paul,
c'est intéressant
de nous rappeler
que nous ne sommes pas
encore parfaitement libres
mais nous sommes déjà
radicalement libres.
On n'est plus
sous les gouvernements
de la chair
ce qui était le cas
avant la conversion.
Si nous sommes
véritablement en Christ,
le Saint-Esprit
il opère en nous
une influence
prédominante
et notre nouvelle nature
a une volonté
prédominante.
Voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul dit
au verset 16
« Marchez selon l'esprit
et vous n'accomplirez
pas les désirs
de la chair
car la chair
a des désirs
contraires
à ceux de l'esprit
et l'esprit
en a des contraires
à ceux de la chair.
Ils sont opposés
entre eux
afin qu'ils vous
n'effaciez
point
ce que vous voudriez. »
Il y a une volonté
prédominante
qui s'accorde
à la volonté
du Saint-Esprit.
C'est ça les chrétiens,
les vrais chrétiens.
Par contre,
il y a encore
les restes
de la chair.
Donc,
à la source
de l'être,
une nouvelle nature
ressuscitée pour Dieu.
Je suis mort
pour la loi
afin de vivre pour Dieu.
C'est ce que Paul
nous a dit déjà
dans cette lettre.
Donc,
je suis né pour Dieu
et ma volonté
prédominante
c'est d'être
tel que Dieu,
de reproduire
la vie de Dieu.
Par contre,
la chair,
verset 24,
a déjà été crucifiée
avec ses passions.
Elle a souffert
un coup mortel,
elle va mourir.
De moins en moins,
elle va faire des appels
et de plus en plus
résistibles seront
ces appels
dans la vie du chrétien.
Cette victoire
est déjà assurée
et à long terme,
la vie du chrétien
sera marquée
par une victoire
prédominante
contre la chair.
Par contre,
cette liberté
qui a eu lieu
à la racine
des lettres
n'est pas,
n'a pas encore
arrivé
à sa totalité.
et donc,
la scientification
restera
une bataille.
Une bataille
qui est
très optimiste
car de notre côté,
les saints-esprits
tout-puissants
sont
mais une bataille
réelle.
Il y a encore
des appels
de la chair
qui vont s'opposer
à la direction
de notre volonté
la plus profonde.
et là,
c'est une discussion
très intéressante
pour toutes les théories
tordues
de la psychanalyse
mais nous ne sommes pas
devant
en cas de bipolarité
ni d'ischizophrénie.
Il faut faire attention
à ne pas traiter
les œuvres de la chair
comme si c'était
des maladies.
Ici,
nous sommes devant
surtout quand on est
en train de considérer
les chrétiens
la réalité
d'une bataille.
Des fois,
les personnes disent
« Je me sentirais
un hypocrite
si je résiste à ça
car mes sentiments
sont vers cette personne.
Je n'ai plus
de passion
ou de sentiments
pour mon épouse. »
Ce sont les appels
non
d'une personne
schizophrénique.
Ce sont les appels
de sa chair.
Car tous les indices
bibliques
qui satisfont
la conscience
et qui ultimement
ont plus
des capacités
de satisfaire
véritablement
l'âme
de régénérer
pointent
dans la direction
opposée.
Et nous n'avons
jamais été appelés
pour être
avant tout
joyeux.
La joie
est toujours
la conséquence
de la sanctification
car Dieu sait
infiniment mieux
que nous-mêmes
ce qui nous fait
vraiment joyeux.
l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles
il y a beaucoup
de carnalités
dans nos églises
aujourd'hui
c'est car
on a cédé
énormément
à ce langage.
On a oublié
en fait
que les termes
psyché
veulent dire
âme.
Et les médecins
de l'âme
c'est Christ.
Cette discipline
elle est très récente
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité.
la psychologie
la psychanalyse
avec des présupposés
complètement opposés
à la Bible.
Et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que les traitements
bibliques
envers les péchés
c'est jamais
de supprimer
la coupabilité.
C'est d'assumer
la coupabilité
la responsabilité
car notre problème
radical devant Dieu
c'est notamment
la coupabilité.
Sans considérer
la coupabilité
on n'a pas besoin
du Christ.
Et en ayant
Christ devant
nos coupabilités
on a non seulement
celui qui peut
nous absoudre
totalement
de nos fautes
et pourvoir
la substance
nécessaire
par son esprit
pour changer
pour résister
pour surmonter.
Et donc
dans cette bataille
on ne va pas
se victimiser
on va savoir
discerner
ce qu'il y a
de la chair
de l'esprit
et faire
ce qu'il faut.
Et donc
dans cette bataille
d'un côté
il faut résister
aux appels
de la chair
on a déjà considéré
les œuvres
de la chair
il faut bien connaître
et résister
de manière
promptive
et de l'autre côté
c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire
à partir du dimanche dernier
c'est de considérer
les fruits
de l'esprit.
Comment je peux
mieux me connaître
à point de savoir
discerner
les appels
ou les influences
qui sont exercées
à la source
de mon être.
Très bien connaître
les œuvres de la chair
encore mieux connaître
les fruits
de l'esprit.
La vérité
pour nous
centrale
c'est
que les fruits
de l'esprit
sont une évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour identifier
un vrai chrétien
un vrai héritier
du royaume
donc les versets
lorsqu'il
finit
de décrire
les œuvres de la chair
il va dire
au verset 20
la partie B
lisez avec moi
je vous dis d'avance
comme je l'ai déjà dit
que ceux qui commettent
des telles choses
n'hériteront point
les royaumes des dieux
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui vivent
dans la pratique
prédominante
de ces œuvres
de la chair
l'impudicité
l'impureté
la dissolution
idolâtrie
magie
inimitié
querelle
jalousie
animosité
dispute
division
secte
envie
ivronnierie
excédentable
si la vie
est marquée
de manière
prédominante
par ses œuvres
par quelques
de ses œuvres
par une
nous sommes devant
une évidence
très lourde
du manque
de conversion
par contre
ce qu'il peut
être en train de faire
c'est d'écrire
une vie
marquée
par ces choses
c'est pas
une chute
une période
de l'autre côté
ce que Paul
va présenter
c'est que
ces personnes
qui pratiquent
ces choses
ne peuvent pas
être reconnues
comme un héritier
du roi des dieux
avec beaucoup
de sagesse
pour qu'on ait
pas l'idée
qu'ici en faisant
des efforts
pour résister
à ces choses
que j'essaierai
sauvées par ma
performance
on est devant
un héritier
c'est une question
de constater
la nature
de la personne
si on veut
faire des tests
pour savoir
si c'est mon enfant
on va faire un test
de sa nature
de son ADN
c'est à dire
s'il n'y a pas
de similarité
dans les caractères
dans la personnalité
et dans la vie
de cette personne
avec les caractères
et la personnalité
des dieux
conclusion
il n'a pas
l'ADN des dieux
les Saint-Esprit
il n'est pas né
de nouveau
vous êtes avec moi
et de l'autre côté
les fruits de l'esprit
nous est présenté
de cette manière
pour renforcer
davantage
les faits
que nous ne sommes
pas devant
des conditions
aucune personne
ne peut produire
les fruits de l'esprit
de soi-même
quand on lit
ses vertus
amour
joie
paix
on pense qu'on peut
trouver ces choses
même chez les non-croyants
et voilà pourquoi
on a mal compris
ce qu'il y a
les fruits de l'esprit
et donc
est une évidence
nécessaire
sans ça
il n'y a pas
de chrétien
et suffisante
car c'est
quel est le Saint-Esprit
qui peut produire
donc si nous trouvons
ces choses
chez une personne
c'est suffisant
pour être sûr
qu'il y en a
devant un chrétien
et donc on doit
avoir cette préoccupation
la question clé
pour nous
c'est comment
identifier les fruits
de l'esprit
de manière authentique
et je vous présenterai
cinq caractéristiques
pour reconnaître
la nature
et les fonctionnements
essentiels
du fruit de l'esprit
aujourd'hui
et après
nous allons revenir
pour mieux comprendre
bibliquement
ce qu'il y a
chacune de ses vertus
pour être davantage
assurés
qu'ils ne sont pas
devant des vertus
naturelles
humaines
la première caractéristique
du fruit de l'esprit
c'est qu'il est
organique
il est appelé fruit
c'est un contraste
dans les contextes
avec les œuvres
de la chair
pour nous rappeler
qui c'est
que la chair produit
nous pouvons avoir
les droits d'auteur
tous les péchés
mentionnés
ce sont des choses
qui viennent
de nous-mêmes
dans la nature
corrompue
ou après la conversion
des restes
de notre nature
corrompue
les appels
de la chair
par contre
ces fruits
sont attribués
au Saint-Esprit
personne
sans le Saint-Esprit
ne peut avoir
ces fruits
ici
il est appelé
fruit
ce n'est pas
un langage
exclusif
au ministère
du Saint-Esprit
ou au fruit
de l'esprit
car il y a d'autres passages
où on va parler
des mauvais fruits
des mauvais arbres
nous avec une nature
mauvaise
on portait
des mauvais fruits
par contre
dans les passages
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
l'intentionnalité
de Paul
d'avoir parlé
des œuvres
de la chair
car toute la lettre
des Galates
c'est une performance
religieuse
qu'on veut présenter
à Dieu
nos efforts
notre transpiration
et il veut
qu'on soit sûr
en fait
que quand on parle
des manifestations
de l'esprit
on ne soit pas
devant
quelque chose
qu'on puisse
produire
de nous-mêmes
voilà pourquoi
il l'appelle
fruit
l'emphase
donc
c'est une emphase
organique
et ce que nous devons
considérer
c'est que c'est
les résultats
de cette union
spirituelle
avec les Christs
Jésus-Christ
il a décrit
la conversion
comme ça a été
rappelé
dans l'introduction
et aussi
par la prière
du frère Moïse
il est l'écep
nous sommes les serments
on a été
greffé à Christ
donc cette illustration
elle est très puissante
nous étions
comme un charbon
un petit morceau
de bois
mort
prêt à être
lancé
dans les feux
on était
si on considère
qu'on était
quelque part
vivant
non de manière
spirituelle
on était
un arbre
mauvais
qui portait
des mauvais
fruits
lorsque nous sommes
sauvés
c'est comme si
Dieu
nous coupe
de cette
mauvaise nature
et va nous greffer
dans cet arbre
bien sûr que la réalité
est spirituelle
le Saint-Esprit
est celui
qui va nous greffer
ou nous unir
à Christ
et la santé
de l'arbre
l'assurance
qu'elle va
prospérer
ne peut pas
venir d'un petit
branche
vous voyez combien
on joue
pas
et tout simplement
contrairement
à la conversion
et à la sanctification
donc
étant greffé
à Christ
la sève
la nature
la santé
spirituelle
ne dépend pas
de notre performance
religieuse
on reçoit
de la part
du Christ
ses influences
par son esprit
et ça va
inévitablement
restaurer
cette branche
que nous sommes
progressivement
supprimant
les restes
de l'influence
de la chair
jusqu'à ce que
dans la gloire
on sera
pleinement glorifié
et donc
c'est intéressant
tous les efforts
des judaïsants
des pôles
avant la conversion
rendaient
incapables
à causer
l'infirmité
de la chair
on n'était pas
greffé à Christ
lié à Dieu
par l'esprit
et pour plus
qu'on faisait
d'efforts
devant la loi
on ne produisait
qu'un péché
par contre
quand on considère
cette transformation
produite par les
saints esprits
chez les croyants
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
au verset 23
il dit
après avoir décrit
les fruits de l'esprit
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
nous sommes
en train de voir
l'apôtre Paul
qui est en train
de pointer
envers la substance
réelle de la loi
une personne
greffée à Christ
sans la loi
mènera
progressivement
une vie
conforme
à la loi
une personne
sauvée par Christ
avec la loi
a la capacité
de faire
les bons usages
de la loi
et progresser
davantage
dans sa sainteté
mais une personne
qui n'est pas
greffée à Christ
avec la loi
elle ne sera
qu'est condamnée
et tentée
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
car
le même esprit
qui est la substance
réelle de la loi
est celui
qui produit
organiquement
ce que la loi
pouvait décrire
mais pas produire
les croyants
progressent
en conformité
naturelle
envers la loi
car
il est en train
de vivre
la substance
de la loi
le Saint-Esprit
lui-même
indépendamment
de son niveau
de connaissance
de la loi
les chrétiens
progressent
en conformité
avec la loi
la loi
où les chrétiens
est en harmonie
avec l'essence
authentique
de la loi
voilà pourquoi
Paul parle
des œuvres
de la loi
pourquoi il parle
des œuvres
de la chair
mais il parle
du fruit
organique
de son esprit
les fruits
de l'esprit
ne peuvent pas
être produits
par les efforts
en gros
Christ
est présent
chez les vrais
chrétiens
à la source
de son être
et ça va
traverser
toutes ses facultés
toute sa constitution
et s'est manifesté
progressivement
c'est plus moi
qui vis
c'est Christ
qui vit en moi
ça c'est la description
du chrétien
ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit chercher
à constater
dans nos vies
nous ne pouvons pas
nous reposer
et croire être sauvés
jusqu'à ce qu'on ne voit pas
cette influence
s'exercer sur nos vies
et qu'elle soit progressive
en même temps
quelle assurance
devant la moindre
manifestation
suffisante
quel est le problème
des Galates
ils avaient bien commencé
mais des mauvaises influences
ont changé
leur conception
de la sanctification
et parfois
c'est le problème
de plusieurs personnes
à l'église
ils ont commencé
bien organiquement
naturellement
après avoir été sauvés
ils marchent bien
ils avancent
après
la culture d'une église
peut devenir tellement
légaliste
tellement contaminée
par la performance
religieuse
par le ritualisme
par l'engagement
dans les activités
de l'église
et on commence
à se comparer
on commence à avoir
des disputes
des sectes
des jalousies
comme pour les Galates
si la personne
après avoir commencé
organiquement
par l'esprit
développe
une vision
artificielle
elle peut être
une belle plante
artificielle
extérieure
mais sans
l'aspect organique
dans sa vie
donc c'est
très important
de faire attention
car
des fois
ces personnes
vont succomber
aux pressions
d'un environnement
légaliste
ils pensent avoir
perdu leur salut
leur chance
de se sanctifier
rater l'occasion
d'être à la portée
du pardon
des dieux
et en se sentant
complètement condamné
ou coupé
du Christ
ils partent
vers les mondes
pour s'effoncer
davantage dans
leurs péchés
car ils ont développé
une performance
une vie performatique
une conception
performatique
des sanctifications
ils ont oublié
l'importance
du pardon
du Saint-Esprit
renouvelé constamment
pour restaurer
leur âme
pour pire
que David
ait tombé
dans les péchés
il n'a jamais
considéré
avoir perdu
son salut
restaure en moi
la joie
du salut
et même
s'il savait
que ces péchés
ont impliqué
beaucoup
des disciplines
il savait
que devant Dieu
s'il était pardonné
il disait
c'est toi
qui relève
ma tête
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
c'est organique
car si
on a déjà vécu
la moindre manifestation
convaincante
suffisante
d'avoir été
l'objet
peut-être
au départ
de la foi
de l'oeuvre réelle
et authentique
du Saint-Esprit
même si on est
éloigné
le Saint-Esprit
ne nous relâche pas
Lord Jones
il disait
que la pire personne
c'est la personne
égagée de l'église
il n'a pas
de citoyenneté
la personne
qui est
bien avec Dieu
proche du Saint-Esprit
à l'église
c'est quelqu'un
qui est dans son environnement
la personne
qui est dans les mondes
qui n'a jamais
expérimenté
la conversion
elle est aussi
quelque part
bien
dans son environnement
bien sûr
en supprimant
les appels
à la répentance
il est conscient
de ses péchés
mais il est plongé
dans ses péchés
il prend plaisir
dans son péché
le problème
c'est qu'un vrai chrétien
lorsqu'il s'égare
il n'a pas
de citoyenneté
c'est comme
les seules
j'étais
il n'arrive
ni à voir
les plaisirs
que les non-chrétiens
ont dans les péchés
dans le monde
ni à voir
les plaisirs
devant Dieu
et la réalité
c'est qu'ici
nous sommes devant
la réalité
de cette persévérance
aussi du Saint-Esprit
donc c'est une assurance
car si
on est devant
une personne
que nous sommes
plutôt rassurés
on a vécu
avec les mieux
de leur foi
et qu'il a été
un exemple
des chrétiens
où le Saint-Esprit
travaillait dans sa vie
nous pouvons
avoir l'assurance
que plutôt plus tard
il sert à redresser
c'est intéressant
car selon
cette description aussi
quand c'est une influence
organique
liée à notre nouvelle
nature prédominante
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
combien ça demande
de nous
de ne pas produire
les fruits
de son Saint-Esprit
vous comprenez ?
la réalité
c'est que je dois
être beaucoup plus
en train de cultiver
et s'aimer
les pratiques
de la chair
pour pouvoir
pécher
et me plonger
dans un péché
l'enseignement
biblique
c'est pas
attention
ce n'est pas
que si nous sommes
tout simplement
livrés à nous-mêmes
dans notre neutralité
la chair
prend l'avance
la nouvelle nature
elle est
envers Dieu
envers la sainteté
le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
la troisième personne
de la sainteté
exerce son influence
la seule chose
qui peut justifier
un tel égarément
chez un chrétien
c'est d'avoir
résisté
à plusieurs reprises
les influences
du Saint-Esprit
les démons
de sa nouvelle nature
d'avoir
notamment cultivé
ses mauvaises passions
c'est comme dit
Thomas Watson
nous ne pouvons pas
empêcher
que les oiseaux
survolent nos têtes
mais nous pouvons
empêcher
qu'ils fassent
des lits
dans notre tête
donc les appels
de la chair
par contre
comment réagir
comment résister
quelle est l'occupation
prédominante
de ma vie
qu'est-ce qui caractérise
mon quotidien
et donc
c'est très avertissant
de prendre en considération
quelle est notre
nouvelle nature
et quel avertissement
en fait
contre
avoir permis
avoir négligé
le Saint-Esprit
avoir permis
que la chair
prenne de l'avance
mais c'est aussi
un grand espoir
pour les saisons
les moins fructifères
car
nous sommes organiquement
liés au Saint-Esprit
un deuxième aspect
c'est que
les fruits de l'esprit
sont espritual
c'est-à-dire
comme l'origine
c'est le Saint-Esprit
donc verset 22
les fruits
de l'esprit
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénignité
la fidélité
la douceur
et la tempérance
ne peuvent pas
être compris
comme des vertus
naturels
c'est quelque chose
qui ne vient
qu'à l'esprit
et donc
son spirituel
c'est lié
au ministère
du Saint-Esprit
ce sont des choses
qui ne peuvent pas
être produites
par l'esprit
Ézéchiel 36
26-27
je vous donnerai
un coeur nouveau
et je mettrai
en vous
un esprit nouveau
et jetterai
de votre corps
le coeur
des pierres
et je vous donnerai
un coeur nouveau
c'est de ça
dont on parle
quand on lit
les fruits
de l'esprit
on n'est pas
devant la considération
de chercher
à produire
avec plus d'effort
ces choses
dans nos vies
comme si on était
au contrôle
de pouvoir
nous exprimer
dans nos relations
dans la société
par une vie
qui quantitativement
sera plus caractérisée
par ces éléments
on est devant
une compréhension
pour chacune
de ces vertus
qui est directement
liée
à la question
spirituelle
ce sont des choses
générées
par les Saint-Esprits
qui trouvent
leur siège
dans la source
de l'être
vous êtes avec moi
un autre esprit
c'est un changement
à la source
de l'être
de la nouvelle nature
c'est qu'il y a donc
des natures
essentiellement
et profondément
spirituelles
et c'est comme Paul
il va dire
en roman
qui la loi
est spirituelle
mais moi
je suis charnel
donc comment
nous devons comprendre
et c'est possiblement
l'une des choses
les plus importantes
à comprendre
ces vertus
elles ne sont pas
atteignables
en termes
quantitatifs
c'est à dire
un croyant
a un peu plus
de capacité
d'exercer
ces vertus
qu'en ont chrétien
non
il n'a pas
un peu plus
lui seul
les chrétiens
a la capacité
de vivre ces choses
c'est pas que
les chrétiens
aient sa vie
marquée
plus par la manifestation
des œuvres
de la chair
qu'il est
fruit de l'esprit
il ne peut pas
porter
les fruits de l'esprit
elles ne peuvent pas
être comprises
tout simplement
comme des vertus
naturelles
les vertus naturelles
qui les êtres
possèdent
et qu'ils manifestent
ce sont les restes
de l'image des dieux
l'image des dieux
chez tous les êtres
humains
n'a pas été
totalement supprimée
mais elle a été
radicalement corrompue
et cette corruption
radicale
chez l'être humain
a contaminé
toutes les manifestations
de ces vertus
le problème
c'est qu'ici
nous ne sommes pas
devant
des vertus
qui puissent être
considérées
comme tout simplement
les manifestations
des restes
car parfois
on sait
que l'être humain
il peut quand même
dans son péché
manifester
de l'amour
envers l'autre
des prochains
il peut sembler
être plus doux
être pacifique
patient
mais les problèmes
c'est qu'on ne peut
pas confondre
ici nous ne sommes pas
dans la description
d'un tempérament
par exemple
comme un chiant
il y a certains chiens
qui disent
il est plus calme
il est doux
et l'autre
il est plus agressif
on n'est pas
devant des choses
déterminées
par la nature
par notre constitution
nous sommes
variables
en termes
de tempérament
d'inclination
naturelle
ici ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qui puisse tout simplement
être une caractéristique
par exemple
si on pense
à la joie
ce n'est pas une personne
qui est toujours
en train de rigoler
de faire des blagues
la patience
n'est pas
une personne
qui est tout simplement
lâche parfois
car c'est facile
d'être patient
sans avoir de l'amour
sans avoir de l'intérêt
vraiment
pour les biens
des personnes
et cet amour
parfois
nous pousse
à la confrontation
à l'exhortation
à la discipline
la patience
n'est pas la lâcheté
si on pense
par exemple
à la bénignité
Augustin lui-même
il disait
même la libéralité
peut
se cacher
derrière la cape
de la libéralité
mais ces personnes
sont en train
de faire
une bonne chose
par la mauvaise motivation
être vu
comme les généreux
il faut savoir
si vraiment
l'être au monde
dans sa condition pécheresse
aurait la capacité
d'exercer
les moindres
de ses éléments
ou de manifester
chacune de ses vertus
telles que
nous devons les présenter
spirituellement
à la source
de l'être
non seulement
nous sommes devant
quelque chose
qui ne peut pas être compris
de manière naturelle
ce sont des choses
qui sont
ultimement
inatteinables
car dans la définition
biblique de ces termes
nous trouvons
une conception
profondément spirituelle
ces vertus
elles sont
les fruits
de la présence
de son esprit
quand on pense
par exemple
à l'amour
la joie
la paix
c'est une manifestation
de la vie
des dieux
en nous
c'est une manifestation
des dieux
en nous
c'est la personne
des dieux
par l'esprit
qui se manifeste
c'est la personne
du Christ
qui se manifeste
en nous
par son esprit
lorsqu'il nous
traversons
une expérience
de conversion
on arrive
à mieux comprendre
comment
l'amour
reçu
de la part
des dieux
est la source
de toutes
ses vertus
car on a
reçu
l'amour
des dieux
par la contemplation
de sa personne
avec l'ensemble
de son amour
et son oeuvre
révélées envers nous
et quand on lit
les béatitudes
c'est la description
d'un caractère
spirituel
où Christ
va manifester
heureux
par exemple
les pauvres
en esprit
heureux
les misérables
spirituels
c'est la perception
d'avoir reçu
attention
un amour
de la part
des dieux
qui malgré
ce qu'on méritait
l'enfer
il nous a aimé
comme si
avec le même amour
qu'il aime
son fils
malgré notre
pauvreté spirituelle
qui ont mérité
l'enfer
malgré notre misère
il nous a aimé
pourquoi
c'est que les chrétiens
qui comprennent
la nature
de cet amour
car les chrétiens
il est le seul
qui n'a pas
résisté
à reconnaître
sa culpabilité
et ses fautes
qui n'a pas cherché
à supprimer
la culpabilité
de sa vie
mais qui a compris
sa misère spirituelle
pour servir
d'arrière-plan
pour chérir
l'amour
infini
des dieux
envers nous
comment un chrétien
peut dire
qu'il aime
s'il n'a pas
la capacité
d'aimer
la seule chose
dans l'univers
qui est pleinement
digne d'amour
comment il peut dire
qu'il aime
si au même temps
qu'il pratique
cet amour
très superficiel
et très corrompu
il tourne les dos
contre les plus
excellentes
manifestations
d'amour
de la part de Dieu
en même temps
tout va venir
de ces premiers éléments
l'amour
c'est l'amour
de Dieu
révélé à nous
dans notre rédemption
qui portera
son impact
sur la vie
de chrétien
quelle est la joie
de celui
qui peut
avoir beaucoup
de divertissement
dans la vie
lorsqu'il est comparé
à la joie
de celui
qui a été délivré
de l'enfer
pour être réconcilié
avec la source
suprême
de la joie
et qui sera dirigé
de manière
victorieuse
et résistible
à la gloire future
vous comprenez
impossible
de trouver
cette joie
chez les chrétiens
impossible
de ne pas
trouver
cette joie
chez les vrais chrétiens
sauf si
il traverse
une période
charnelle
mondaine
un résistant
de cultiver
la joie
où il devrait cultiver
et de croire
dans les mensonges
de ce monde
la foire
de la vanité
il serait plus
dans la joie
si j'ai plus
si cette bénédiction
arrive dans ma vie
parce que la bénédiction
suprême
est déjà là
l'amour
de Dieu
envers moi
et ça va se suivre
et nous allons voir
avec tous les autres éléments
cette paix
quelle paix
a un non-chrétien
si sa conscience
est constamment
en train
de l'accuser
quelqu'un a déjà dit
c'est le même passage
c'est comme s'ils avaient
une couverture
quand on va dormir là
comment on dit
en couverture
courte
on essaye
de couvrir la poitrine
les pieds
vont souffrir
les froids
ils essayent
de supprimer
leur conscience
en faisant
leur séance
de psychanalyse
en faisant
leur voyage
en prenant
leur psychotrope
on cache
la chose
d'un côté
on expose
la chose
de l'autre
c'est l'inconnance
en incohérence
les manques
de paix
de la paix
véritable
la paix
du pardon
parfait
la paix
d'une approbation
d'une acceptation
absolue
irrévocable
mon enfant
impossible
de virer
mon amour
pour toi
la paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
quelle est l'attente
qui repose
sur la patience
d'un chrétien
c'est la longue
limitée des dieux
nous avons connu
la longue limitée
des dieux
et donc
nous allons
subir
à des réproches
car
d'un côté
on a tous
goûté
si nous sommes
vraiment chrétiens
ces caractères
la révélation
de cette personne
quelque part
cette expérience
qui a marqué
les débuts
de notre foi
une connaissance
de Dieu
où on a reçu
cet amour
qui nous a apporté
ces traitements
cette joie
cette paix
cette patience
cette montée
cette bénignité
et la réponse
naturelle
c'est que la vie
des dieux
qui a été révélée
en nous
soit la vie
des dieux
qui est manifestée
en nous
à travers les autres
et envers Dieu
comprenez déjà
pourquoi
on n'est pas devant
une caractéristique
qui puisse être
considérée
comme une caractéristique
naturelle
c'est
dès l'esprit
son origine
et ce n'est pas
une question
on n'est pas devant
des choses
qu'on puisse faire
ou trouver
mais d'une manifestation
qui a été faite
envers nous
et qui s'est reproduite
dans la manière
dont on vit
et donc
nous sommes devant
la restauration
d'un caractère spirituel
de la vie
des dieux
en nous
de cette symétrie
parfaite du Christ
dans nos vies
elle ne peut pas
être produite
car c'est tout simplement
la manifestation
du Saint-Esprit
des dieux
en nous
les fruits de l'esprit
est donc
organique
et spirituel
les fruits de l'esprit
est aussi
sangulier
indivisible
parce que nous voyons
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
on peut avoir
l'impression
qu'il soit
des choses
qu'on puisse
s'efforcer
pour les produire
certainement
nous pouvons
cultiver
de manière
consciente
chacune
de ces choses
ou chacune
de ces facettes
mais les fruits
nous sont présentés
dans les sanguliers
pour renforcer
les points
qui ne sont pas
devant
la manifestation
tout simplement
des qualités
nous sommes devant
la manifestation
d'un caractère
Dieu est amour
un amour
qui se manifeste
par toutes ces facettes
nous sommes restaurés
à l'image
de Dieu
!
Dieu
est un amour
une personne
et la personne
qui nous devons être
est en conformité
à la personne
du Christ
c'est de considérer
!
l'équilibre
la symétrie
!
de ces perfections
par exemple
nous voyons
la connexion
directe
entre
chacune
de ces facettes
comment l'amour
amène à la joie
la joie
à la paix
la paix
à la patience
etc
la tempérance
même
pourquoi
un chrétien
il est
il a la capacité
de se maîtriser
particulièrement
en faisant
la confrontation
avec les oeuvres
de la chair
avec l'excès
de table
la tempérance
elle est
l'expression
du contentement
on ne manque pas
d'équilibre
car on a déjà
tout récemment
quel est le contraste
avec les manques
de tempérance
selon
l'apôtre Paul
quand il écrit
aux éphésiens
il va dire
ne vous inhibirez pas
du vent
mais remplissez-vous
du Saint-Esprit
c'est le contentement
c'est d'avoir reçu
du Saint-Esprit
cette satisfaction
cette consolation
qu'on est en train
de chercher ailleurs
cette exagération
à travers
les entorpeçons
toutes choses
qui peuvent enlever
un abordage rationnel
de la réalité
et le Saint-Esprit
est celui
qui vient apporter
ses vertus
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
par exemple
quand on va confronter
les fruits de l'Esprit
aux œuvres de la chair
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment
quelques groupes
des facettes
du fruit
se reportent
directement
au péché
de la chair
ce qui est intéressant
de remarquer
c'est que l'être humain
dans son péché
il n'est pas
intègre
il est fragmenté
les péchés
partent
dans toutes les directions
il y a plein
d'incohérences
c'est une vie
complètement fragmentée
il peut
s'éporter dans la société
comme s'il était
un modèle
dans cette ère
de sa vie
en même temps
qu'il est
un infidèle
dans sa vie privée
il peut sembler
être très
raisonnable
et tempérant au travail
mais on ne sait pas
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
en arrivant à la maison
combien d'alcool
il va ingérer
il est fragmenté
et là c'est intéressant
Paul va reprocher
par les œuvres de la chair
les religieux
et les païens
les œuvres de la chair
peuvent se manifester
avec un zèle
fanatique
religieux
qui devient agressif
impatient
envers ceux
qui n'ont pas encore
atteint
leurs critères
de sanctification
leurs paramètres
leur manière
de s'habiller
par exemple
l'assiduité
aux réunions
de l'église
et de l'autre côté
Paul va parler aussi
des problèmes
qui caractérisent plus
la vie des païens
l'intempérance
l'idolâtrie
la magie
etc
les œuvres de la chair
sont en train
de se manifester
dans toutes
les directions
par contre
les fruits
de l'esprit
portent
cette
symétrie
cet équilibre
que personne
ne peut
dissimuler
personne
ne peut
dissimuler
à long terme
c'est un équilibre
il peut y avoir
des moments
ponctuels
des rechutes
mais sa vie
ne sera pas
caractérisée
par l'animosité
par les accès
de colère
l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
est une constante
dans sa vie
même dans ces moments
de rechutes
le Saint-Esprit
il agit très vite
pour les corriger
pour l'amener
à la répentance
elle n'aura pas
de difficultés
par exemple
elle ne devrait pas
avoir la difficulté
de demander du pardon
de s'humilier
car elle est douce
elle se voit
par la perspective
de celui
qui a été écrasé
par la santé des dieux
il ne veut pas
se défendre
sa réputation
devant les personnes
car il sait
qu'il est devant Dieu
il a déjà dû traiter
devant Dieu
à cause de ses péchés
personne ne peut
reproduire
l'équilibre
du caractère chrétien
c'est la vie
du Saint-Esprit
certains veulent
se vanter
de pouvoir
manifester
les dons
de l'Esprit
mais à partir
du moment
on sort
de l'église
et qu'on va
à un resto
et on voit
les traitements
qu'un soi-disant apôtre
donne
à un serviteur
on se demande
si le Saint-Esprit
habite dans son cœur
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénéglité
la fidélité
la douceur
la tempérance
tous ces éléments
ensemble
ils ne sont pas exhaustifs
mais sont suffisants
tous ces éléments
doivent se manifester
dans nos vies
de manière équilibrée
tous doivent
se manifester
et en même temps
et même si
dans certaines phases
de nos vies
certains se soient
manifestés
de manière plus intense
que d'autres
ou dans des phases
infructifères
en cédant la chair
ils peuvent être
beaucoup moins évidents
c'est la manifestation
de Dieu
de sa personne
et de la personne
qu'il est en train
de former en nous
on va s'arrêter ici
aujourd'hui
le temps ne permet pas
d'avancer
nous sommes devant
les caractères spirituels
de l'image
de Dieu
nous ne pouvons pas
nous reposer
jusqu'à ce qu'on ne trouve pas
ces évidences
dans son ensemble
dans nos vies
ces influences
nous sommes devant
une personnalité
cohérente
intègre
voilà pourquoi on parle
d'intégrité
équilibrée
symétrique
et pour mieux comprendre
toutes ces choses
il faut qu'on contemple
surtout
notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et c'est ça
qu'on verra par la suite
levons-nous pour prier
et c'est ça
le fait
de la suite
c'est ça